i don't buy these reductionist
theories i think you know i've made the
metaphor
that uh the discovery the great
intellectual adventure or one of them of
the 20th century has been the discovery
and description of the unconscious
and it begins with freud who discovered
that people have dirty minds essentially
in other words he just dropped down
one level and saw that there was this
whole cycle mental life which nobody was
talking about
but which was all tied up with how we
really think and feel
and then no sooner had he gotten this
fairly well
laid out and working the way he wanted
then his student
jung broke away from him and said yes
that's all true but the entire sexual
complex
has to be centered in a larger sphere
which i will call the collective
unconscious
and which will include not simply
personal traumatic material and
repressed
wish fulfillment and all this stuff but
also
the traumatic material and suppressed
wish fulfillment and psychic
dominance of the species and this seemed
like a very far
out idea it meant that we were all
somehow connected and that
cultural patterns you see in the 19th
century they always tried to trace on
the ground
how a goddess or a magical belief
got from one place to another because
they reasoned how else could it be
transmitted
young blows that all up and says well
people will spontaneously event
invent the same religious forms the same
rituals the same notions worldwide
because that's just how people are
now i think that what the the tryptamine
hallucinogens hold out is
a new level in defining and enunciating
what the unconscious is
it's that beyond the freudian position
beyond the jungian concern with the
images embedded in the species mind
actually a major portion of what's
called the unconscious
has nothing to do with human beings
and is much more like a landscape
or a place than it is like
repressed memories or archetypal images
it simply is a place and
many researchers have confirmed that
when you take psychedelics
when they start people out on lsd the
first
trips are usually uh personalistically
oriented
how screwed up i am i don't love the
right people i don't like myself
i'm not doing it all this and it's very
painful for people because
it is condensed psychoanalysis basically
but if they will persist and many people
don't they just say my god who needs
this i'm worried enough as it is i don't
need
to dwell but if you if you persist
then uh that stops because you can only
be
so screwed up you know and and you get
it worked out you actually come into
a place of maturity then the jungian
survey of these deeper levels of the
psyche these contact with dominance
seems to be what the psychedelic
experience is and the dominance
though are usually presented as
guardians of gateways
almost in a gnostic schema where the
soul has to ascend through gateways to
escape
the machinery of fate if you persist
beyond that
you reach the topology that shamanism
describes a place with a howling wind
a doorway onto a desolate plain a
howling wind
all these descriptions but the main
stress
is geological and topological a
surface into which you go no longer
self-doubting
or you know not at least so
self-doubting that it's interfering with
your functioning
and this dimension is the one that is
real puzzling
because if it was puzzling to explain
how the jungian
information was coded in the brain it's
even more puzzling to help
explain how these topologies with
no apparent tangentiality to human
concerns could be there
and i think that what's going to have to
give way to assimilate all this
is the notion that the mind is
something causally related to the brain
i don't think it is and this has been an
article of faith
for 200 years that eventually we would
show
that the activity at first chemical and
finally electrical
of the brain is causally related to
thought i don't think it is i
think that uh that there that the hidden
force in the world that all the shouting
and jumping up and down
but it's about is mind and that it that
the brain
is a piano and the mind is horowitz
and you will never
and you will never understand horowitz
by picking apart the piano
now the if the problem here is it sounds
like an absolute dualism
if the mind is not uh is not
an electrical the the ongoing electrical
functioning of
the of the brain what is it
i think that it's the part of the human
body that you can't
see it's an organ but you know
who has seen their pancreas yet we all
believe
it's there well but notice that there's
something odd about
if you think of people as objects which
you're not supposed to do by the way
but if you think of them as objects for
a moment you notice something very odd
about them that they are a very special
class of objects
they change through time stones
chairs buildings these things don't but
the class of objects
called people change through time it's
almost as though
taught for a person to exist
there has to be an added dimension
no object can live so that people
are hyper dimensional objects the fact
of our living
proves that we're hyper dimensional
objects we require
the dimension of time in order to be a
rock
doesn't i mean a rock is fully a rock in
a microsecond
a person is not fully a person except in
a lifetime
or at least certainly a span of time
longer than a microsecond
so so being alive proves that there is
an intersection of a higher
topological manifold and that that's
what biology is
biology is objects which live
objects which have time bounded into
them in some way
well then mindedness is the binding in
of yet a higher dimension
and the brain perceives
the mind but the mind is is not
part of it i think it's another organ of
the body
the brain perceives the stomach when you
say you have a stomach ache
it is your mind i mean it is your brain
which is processing these nerve signals
and telling you
this and the mind is the hidden organ of
the human body
and when you take psychedelics you see
this hidden organ you exercise it you
move
into it and it's a very strange organ
because it has this higher dimensional
quality to it
but it's a part of humanness it can't be
taken away from it but its relationship
to the brain is
is very specious and too much energy
has been put into that the whole problem
you see with psychedelic
drugs is to really understand them
you must take them and this poses
problems
that science normally doesn't have to
grapple with
scientists don't like that they like to
stand as far away from their subject
matter as possible
and believe that it is running through
its changes
completely without their intercession or
input
and we're not getting a good picture of
the activity
of psychedelic drugs by giving them to
prisoners
or to people who have been pre-selected
for some pre-selected
sociopaths
and well no you have to stand into it
this has been the problem
you see the whole thing in the 19th
century all
all sciences wanted to emulate physics
in terms of the elegance of the
predictability the highly mathematicized
way in which quantity could be assigned
to all the values manipulated
and all to be a science that's what it
meant to be as much like
physics as possible and it's always
eluded psychology
i mean psychology is just whistling in
the wind
in terms of being a science because
sciences usually start out with a
definition of their subject matter
and psyche we're still waiting
you know there are only contentious
voices
being heard so i think that the the
challenge of the psychedelics is
a total challenge a challenge to science
a challenge to each of us personally a
challenge
to the notion that history has become an
unavoidable part of being human
and
it's a frontier it's it's the call of
the future and we can
make the future come to be to the degree
that we explore and exemplify this thing
it is you know that mind looms large
in the future of humanity and that
psychedelics are actually catalysts
for mind they speed the cultural
the reaction which we call cultural
development
can be vastly speeded up by the
injection of psychedelics into the
social system
and this is what happened in the 1960s
and people are still
reeling from it and they'll never
recover from it
it was too much and it continues
[Music]
you